okay hi everybody
i think we're back i think i'm finally
live so i was checking out the
new streaming system i have here and uh
it's not streaming to the right url on
my channel but it is streaming to my
channel
just not to the url i told it to so you
hope you guys you will you will find it
and um you guys will make it over here
through the course of the
hangout i am streaming however to dr
brian keating's channel so it is working
on there just fine so we are
back so i was checking out the new
streaming system i have here
and uh it's not streaming to the right
url on my channel
there we go i had too many urls open
sorry about that
okay so wow it's been a while so i'm a
little bit rusty
i want to welcome you guys back to our
uh to our little hangout series this is
something we try and do every
friday well many friday maybe thursdays
uh with dr brian keating who also has a
channel
which is located the link to his uh
channel is located in the
description box below and um
i want to today we're going to be
talking a little bit about
the nobel prize season that is upon us
now this is october this usually is the
time when people
uh start talking about the nobel prize
uh in everything so we're gonna i'm
gonna bring
uh dr keating up here in just a minute
in the meantime i wanna let you guys
know i am
streaming on both dr brian keating's
channel and uh
deep astronomy so please chat and leave
your questions in the chat box and
we will get to them so let me bring
brian up are you there brian
i'm here can you hear me tony i can hear
you loud and clear so welcome back it's
been a while
and uh now
crazy so i a lot of stuff happened uh in
the course of this my streaming
adventures but uh hopefully we'll be
back on track so
um doctor so brian you actually
this is nobel season right this is the
time when
the nobel committee starts announcing
their nobel prizes
and we have uh well
several of them uh that were awarded
this week and the one i think that we're
the most interested in here today is
going to be the one that's
that was announced uh in the uh physics
category so you want to describe to us a
little bit about what that was
and you've interviewed some of these
winners or at least
at least one i know yeah i know
very well sir roger penrose in fact he
has
a project called called the penrose
institute
and they want to have that uh really to
be located hosted at uc san diego where
i am of course the uh chancellor's
distinguished professor you know me as
not super distinguished but i am the
chancellor's distinguished professor of
physics you're super distinguished for
sure
no i try actually uh but uh and i don't
know andre i guess very well
she's uh she's a friend of uc san diego
she's a mentor and a friend to
many astronomers in my in my research
groups uh you know kind of orbit so to
speak and
that's a pun that was intended because
of course she
received it along with reiner genzel for
discoveries related to
tests of not a black hole did you read
the description
it didn't say you know proving a black
hole exists rather it said for uh
for evidence for a compact massive
object at the center of our galaxy
and that was very uh cleverly uh
orchestrated by the nobel committee i
have to give them you know some years
there's good prizes some years there's
questionable prizes
this was certainly a great prize all
around especially
not the least of which because it went
to a close friend who blurbed my book
i mean how often does that happen when a
nobel laureate blurbs a book about
losing the nobel prize
but he's just an incredibly gracious and
wonderful individual
so um so yeah so this this is the prize
for black holes
and there are many many uh related uh
kind of
issues and topics that we can get into
and i also had the pleasure a couple
weeks ago talking to one of the pioneers
modern-day kind of young guns that are
looking at
not only black holes but possibly
wormholes
and wormholes that you could travel
through so you and i tony could finally
meet
and we could be in person together
through a wormhole for our you know some
live stream that we do someday down the
line
i would love that you know the one thing
that i think
i don't think a lot of people realize is
just how recent
it is that the observational evidence
for black holes
uh are i mean we we've theorized they've
been theorized since the uh late 18th
century
but um you know with mathematicians
bringing them up as
as mathematical constructs but it really
i mean i think the eht the event horizon
telescope was the first that really
definitively said
there's one there's a black hole uh
we've actually
seen it uh of course einstein came along
and said they should exist and of course
we've seen a lot of
indirect evidence for black holes
so it's is it this is this idea has been
around for a while but is it because
we've only recently gotten observational
evidence of black holes
that these guys maybe maybe the nobel
committee recognized what they did
yeah you know someone asked me earlier
as i get asked pretty frequently who's
going to win the nobel prize every
i call this the annunciation season you
know i think of nobel prizes as kind of
a religion
and this uh and this this season has
been the
season of annunciation and then the
coronation season happens
not on alfred nobel's birthday but on
his death day which is december 10th
which is basically a national holiday in
sweden and that's
what he called a coronation and we'll
get to that in a minute
so enunciation week i get asked all the
time and i actually predicted
that a black hole project would win it
this year
i didn't predict my friend sir roger
would win it but i did predict that
i thought the event horizon telescope
would win it
uh for imaging the the event horizon
around a black hole which is as
as close as we really have come so the
nobel citation for
guess and genzel um my one of whom is my
colleague within the university of
california system
is uh is cited for um
excited for the compact object and and
that's that's relevant because if you
look at the actual citation
uh the you know they talk about the site
because the reason is you really can't
say for certain that this object is a
black hole
and and and even uh you know the case is
similar
uh in the event horizon telescope you're
not actually seeing a black hole
and right what you're seeing is sort of
the influence of a black hole right
and in fact you know somebody mentioned
you know if you replaced the sun with a
one solar mass black hole
uh we would miss its light but we would
keep orbiting around as we are and we'd
have a 365 and a quarter day year
just like we do now so it's really not
uh commensurate to say that they
discovered a black hole
but in reality they did discover
something very very compact
and that has an effect on the orbits
that it was consistent with
another laureate's predictions although
he didn't win it for this
and we know that as albert uh as albert
einstein
so it's really a confirmation of that uh
that they these two
wanted for and then penrose is sort of
you know
controversial in the sense that his his
citation reads for you know discoveries
uh relevant to general relativity
and really using it as a as a vehicle to
understand relativity
but uh but again you know he's done
tremendous work along with his late
great colleague
stephen hawking who i met a long time
ago in person but
but never had a chance to get him on the
podcast unfortunately but his
predictions were
really related to the discovery of uh
consequences of general relativity which
of course relates from albert einstein
so that was his contribution of
penrose's contribution what about the
other two what were they
what was their contribution and i just
want to point out before you do i want
to say real quick that
you said the eht did not directly see a
black hole and you're right but that is
about as close as we're ever going to
get
to seeing a black hole is to see its
event horizon because
nothing can come out you're always going
to sort of infer their existence on the
things around them
and this is something immediately around
m87 which we did see
and galaxia brings up the point i put up
that that chat there
that you know we can also see the stars
revolving around sagittarius a star
that's the supermassive black gold
center over milky way
is also an inference of a black hole
being there so so
roger penrose led lead very did a lot of
theoretical work predicting what you
should see
based on einstein's relativity uh and
what
and and uh that was his contribution
uh i'm i'm i know i'm oversimplifying
but then the other two what were they
done what did they do
um what were they what were their
contributions
you're exactly right so one of the
things that's important to realize in
science as experimental scientists
or observational astronomers is that we
can't really do an experiment where we
would make a black hole in the
laboratory
play around with it see if it has
certain properties that are expected
we can't visit a black hole we can't
have a black hole interact with
the sun these are not experiments
scientists like us we cannot do
experiments where we have
cause isolate control variable etc like
you learned in high school
instead there are classes of discovery
that we rely upon that are called
indirect
or direct what i study is potentially
the
indirect evidence for gravitational
waves from the ultra early universe
if the universe underwent a period of
extremely rapid inflation
that would produce as a consequence
indirectly gravitational waves
which would then imprint the cosmic
microwave background radiation
imparting onto it a type of polarization
that we call b
mode polarizations twisting curling
rotating pattern of polarization that
was the subject of my book losing the
nobel prize
and instead there are experiments like
ligo which can make a direct detection
wherein a gravitational wave comes into
their laboratory
perturbs it makes certain objects longer
amongst one direction
a perpendicular direction shorter and
they can measure that
that distortion characteristic
distortion in direct
fashion so that's a direct experiment
and
similarly most astronomical experiments
and evidence for particles for fields
for forces like gravitational waves are
only indirect at best
so what these two scientists did with
their huge teams
is they used something called adaptive
optics
which is a technology co-invented by a
very very
famous astronomer also in the university
of california system her name is claire
max
and others pioneered a system that as
colloquially said
to uh to freeze the atmosphere to make
the atmospheric distortions due to
turbulent
fluctuations of the atmospheric water
vapor content
that broiling fluid that we rely upon to
breathe and to live
creates havoc for astronomical
observations so what they did is
developed a technique that could freeze
it and uh
and then the the pioneering work by
guess and by gensol's teams
what they did is apply that in the
infrared and that gets
not only rid of the of the atmospheric
fluctuations but also contamination from
that scourge of nobel prizes everywhere
called dust
so they were able to use infrared
adaptive optics over decades
to trace the orbits of stars of actual
stars honest goodness stars
around an invisible uh spot of matter
that was inferred to be a black hole and
so that's what they did they indirectly
demonstrated
the existence of a compact object which
is has all the properties of a black
hole
different from the properties of a of a
massive
object in three major regards that we
can get into
but the but these contributions are
really applications of technology
uh and observations over decades and
that's what allowed them
to kind of make these predictions of
what you'd see and compare that to what
relativity predicted
yeah so um the
you met you mentioned something when you
were explaining that that i kind of want
to dive into
these days about the way science is done
and that is that
you these these are the recipients of
the nobel prize
in physics for their work but they are
by no means working alone
right i mean these are these are huge in
many cases especially with gravitational
waves you
you can't you can't just use this
equipment all by yourself i mean this
has to come with
huge collaborations does winnie and
nobel prize i mean as these guys
did but they're part of a much bigger
team um
does it does it reflect on the
how do others feel about it i guess
that's my my
my my question because are people being
singled out for any reason i mean who i
don't know what the algorithm is i'm
sure there is one for
deciding on what a nobel prize is who
gets it um but is there any
is there any yeah there's no
left or any of that that's that's sort
of
what my book concerns is that the nobel
prize is a human process it's not like
there's some law of nature
that says this person and that team
deserved a nobel prize
it's highly capricious it's very
selective usually they get things right
in the physics prizes
you can question how well they've done
in the other awards
although there have been some bloopers
in the nobel prize in physics too
uh don't forget uh niels bohr won the
nobel prize for
basically a proposition that the atom is
basically a tiny solar system
in the early 1900s and we know that to
be completely wrong
of course he made some other
contributions as you know in the
copenhagen school
which uh but but despite that and
actually
enrico fermi who is a titanic physicist
of the
of the 20th century his nobel prize was
really uh
incorrectly attributed to the process
that we call
now call fusion but really he was
describing fission
and that so that was a blooper in a
certain sense they got that wrong
but he also is widely respected and and
certainly
uh many believe that he did deserve it
so in the physics prize i would say it's
the least
of the of the blunders and blooper
variety on the other hand all nobel
prizes suffer from the effect of
exclusion
and leaving out these huge teams of
people that without which
make the project impossible it happens
to be that
um there are no other prizes that are as
prestigious there are prizes that pay a
lot more the breakthrough prize pays
perhaps 10 times as much if you win it
by yourself
and uh and can include the entire team
and i know i've received i can't
divulge their names but when ligo won
there are three people who want it
i talk about this in my book how one of
the co-creators of ligo
ron dreever passed away just a few
months too too soon
to have been considered for the nobel
prize in 2017. so it's not given
posthumously then is it
they have given it posthumously twice to
swedish people
to swedes and the literature and peace
prizes uh but they have never given the
physics prize posthumously they've given
the medicine prize posthumously
the they changed the rules in 1974 to
disallow posthumous prizes
and technically that would mean even if
you die the minute before the ceremony
they wouldn't give it to you
there was a case about nine years ago
when a
physician was announced to have won the
nobel prize but when he was announced he
had already died they ended up giving it
to them
now the the issue with posthumous prizes
is
only took place in 1974 and someone like
rosalind franklin therefore was eligible
to win the nobel prize
posthumously because there were no
preclusions against it she died in the
late 1950s i believe
and and uh watson and crick and wilkins
won the nobel prize for dna's
double helix discovery and i think 1963
or so maybe 62 someone can correct me in
the audience uh but she was eligible
back then because they didn't change the
rules for another 12 years so i've
gotten into fights
with the secretary general of the nobel
academy
uh swedish royal academy which rewards
this about this online
laymore i could put a link to that in
the in the chat and maybe people will
find that interesting
well yeah definitely yeah so you're
gonna say you're fighting with them
about this well that's good yeah
um uh i i think
it's hard for something like this to not
get politicized or certainly
uh emotions run pretty high with who
gets the nobel prize and who doesn't
um and in fact if i remember right
please correct me if i tell this story
wrong but
albert einstein did not win the nobel
prize for his work on relativity
uh he won it uh uh for his work on the
photoelectric effect which is the
science that all of our solar panels are
based on
um but did he receive that much later
than people thought he should have got
it i mean it was well into his life
right by the time he got the
nobel prize albert einstein it's yeah
it's so interesting because he
he did receive it in 1920 he received
the 1921
nobel prize which wasn't awarded until
1922 for some reason
uh it wasn't because of a war etc and he
won it as you said
for the photoelectric effect not for
special relativity not for general
relativity
special relativity was predicted by him
in 1905.
general relativity is predicted in 1915.
so there were seven years or maybe even
you know 17 years between these two
different
discoveries which had been borne out now
why was this a problem
well it turned out the most you're
eligible to nominate winners of the
nobel prize if you previously won a
nobel prize
now who was winning nobel prizes in the
early 1900s when einstein could have
been eligible
was mostly german scientist austrian
scientist
eastern european uh and and some western
european scientists that were deeply
anti-semitic in fact
hitler had a whole cadre of what he
called
aryan scientists explicitly working to
prevent people like albert einstein
who is considered to be practicing
jewish science which meant
theoretical signs like philip lenard and
others who discovered the photoelectric
effect real men
real aryans did did experimental work
theoretical work was was was beneath a
real physicist it's funny because
you know i am a uh i am an
experimentalist and i'm also jewish
uh so i probably wouldn't have been too
uh they would have been too fond of me
back then
but uh but the point is the uh he was
precluded now who won the nobel prize
between say 1905 and 1922.
uh one person who won it was a man uh
norwegian or sweden named gustav dalen
now what did he win it for well he
wanted for the impeccable creation
of a type of lighthouse regulating buoy
and and gas accumulator that regulates
the pulsation of lighthouses
he won that in 1912 seven years after
einstein's
uh special relativity now i don't know
about you but you know i
usually navigate using not gps which
relies on general relativity for
corrections but
i use lighthouses and buoys whenever
possible so that certainly has had a
beneficial effect on me
no so there wasn't any yeah exactly so
there's all sorts of politics i always
point out
as happy as i am for the winners as as
much as in the past i certainly want to
win a nobel prize and
and people say i'm a hypocrite or i have
sour grapes you know this is a prize
mainly determined by the whims of about
400
swedish scientists 90 of whom are male
you know and how representative is that
now they often get it right
i think that they did a great job in
this in this year's selection especially
because a woman was selected
for only the fourth time in history and
you know one of my friends was joking
look you're having an impact your book
which says that you know all these women
have been left out just since my book
came out
two women have won it we doubled the
number of female winners just since
losing the nobel prize came out so i
i take full credit for that of course
just kidding yeah
[Laughter]
well it is true they are they have been
widely underrepresented in fact treated
quite unfairly uh throughout the process
so
um how much time do i have with you
brian do you have to go early
no no i can go for another 15 minutes
okay can you stay until maybe maybe four
um yeah another half an hour okay
because i want to i want to go back to
black holes and then i want to go back
to this because i have some other
questions
i've so i've been uh
doing a lot of reading about uh science
scientism and you know a lot of a lot of
areas that that make science
um less accepted by the general public
than it used to be
and one of the things in the course of
my research that or my reading that i
i've come across is this idea that
when we talk about black holes black
holes are by definition
a singularity they are these regions
where
gravity the gravity has gotten so strong
that they have they are regions of
zero volume and infinite density which
is and up to a point
the laws of physics operate within the
guidelines of general relativity
we go towards a black hole space time is
curved uh
extensively and then we reach a point
called the event horizon
which is this point beyond which
we don't know what's going on our laws
of physics
can't help us with goes on with with the
other side
of this uh of this event horizon
do you think that's a problem for
physics if in relativity specifically if
you've got
something in your theory this is my
question
if you've got something in your theory
that contains
singularities like black holes these are
infinite infinities in your math
isn't that a problem for the theory is
it incomplete
is there something that that
is is it like newton's law newton's uh
framework where things are right in a
certain regime
but then they stop being right and then
relativity takes over
uh is there something like that going on
here where relativity is right in a
certain regime
and then beyond that it does not work
very well
i mean yeah our black problem
yeah you're absolutely right and this
has an influence on something else that
you're deeply concerned about
which is uh theories of everything so
you could ask the question as you and i
have talked about it almost two months
ago i can't believe it but you know do
we need a theory of everything
uh someone say yes because uh the laws
of science physics have to obey these
symmetry principles and because
the forces of nature that are long
shorter range and higher strength and
gravity
are all manifest in a quantum domain
they all have quantum mechanical
bosons that mediate the forces that kind
of bind together the particle players
the actors
in the and the grand scheme of quantum
mechanics
but gravity refuses to be quantized for
reasons
uh that we can get into and that we have
no evidence for
the quantum of gravity called the
graviton yet
um that uh but but what if we ask the
question the other hand as you're saying
the two domains in which you might
demand if you're greedy a theory of
everything have to do
with the behavior of gravity near
singularities or in singularities
so first you have to ask a question are
singularities real
what if you found out you know god hands
you a letter and says there's no such
thing as a singularity
we assume there are singularities
because as you say these properties of
of um of black holes seem to demand
the breakdown of classical that means
you know the equations of general
relativity break down
at the very you know center the the zero
radius point from the
uh concentration of mass that we would
call the short child metric
now but what if and the other domain
rather is in the early universe if the
universe began in the singularity right
those are the two regimes
in which you might expect or demand
there to be a singularity and an
explanation
of that uh so those should be you know
fairly common to people
but i always point out is there an
example can you tony can you tell me
an example of some place some phenomena
that is
infinite in strength
are you there tony
tony can you hear me
i hear myself i see myself i think tony
is frozen so i'll keep talking and
hopefully
tony will come back online uh if you're
out in the chat room can you please let
me know if you can still hear me in the
chat
um i don't hear tony he appears to be
frozen like he disappeared into a black
hole
but i can hear myself and i see myself
tony's frozen okay i'm going to keep
talking
so consider if you will in the chat room
tell me an example of some place where
there's an
infinity of a physical quantity not a
mathematical quantity
not you know one divided by zero is
infinity no instead a physical quantity
temperature at the center of the sun is
not infinite the density at the center
of the sun
is not infinite how do you go from
something that is infinite truly
infinite it has a
one over zero in the physics of it the
density the temperature
the matter content that uh then
suddenly tapers away from infinity
of time or now it seems like
uh i have disappeared from tony's
channel but now i see tony tony are you
back
yeah i am back yep we should be here
okay
i was there i think i am still there
yeah sorry about that on my computer
but that's a good test the stream went
on which is great
even though even though i died so um
that's great so i made the joke that you
were
you were frozen as if you had just
disappeared beyond the event horizon of
a black hole
that's what it would look like wouldn't
it exactly so i asked you
uh before you broke out uh you know is
there an example that you can think of
of a
physical quantity that is infinite
anywhere in
the laws of physics that you understand
not not singularities not black nouns
but tell me like oh yeah so what if what
if there is no such thing
then do we need a quantum theory of
gravity i would say maybe not
the other place it comes up is in the us
as in the beginning of
of the universe if the universe
experiences a singularity but as we've
talked about
we don't know for sure if the big bang
was a singularity
and it has uh certain suggestions made
by people like paul steinhardt the
albert einstein professor of natural
science at princeton
and neil turock and others that the
universe is cyclical roger penrose let
me let me just say
i don't have to quote uh paul steinhardt
i can say nobel prize winner
has a theory where there's no inflation
there's no singularity
and that's called the conformal cyclic
cosmology and i have an interview with
him on my on my youtube channel which
you should subscribe to dr brian keaney
on youtube and on twitter find me there
and if you do that
you will find interviews where he talks
about the predictions that we would see
if the universe doesn't have a
singularity so
now we're having you know very very
questionable
considerations do we need to have a
singularity are they really
uh physical and nobody knows for sure so
i always ask the question well that
would help then that would yeah that
would really help them with relativity
if we did not need one right
but then whenever it takes a question
what the hell are black holes then if
if not this so yeah black holes are
these mysterious objects where
relativity you know is uh is so wildly
unpredictable and almost anything goes
and that can happen in the early
universe if the big bang took place in
the singularity
as well but we don't really have um you
know i would say
what if we may never have evidence for
the singularity as you say
and what if there are other you know the
question is can you have the black hole
uh signatures that we do see in other
words how they affect them the stars
that orbit around them as gaz and genzyl
imaged
as you uh or if they have the properties
that ligo can measure
the spin they're charged or magnetic
fields perhaps
how can they be used to test the
properties of general relativity
and reveal whether or not we need a
quantum description of gravity which
brings us maybe if you're willing to go
there
to my conversation with juan maldasena
at the institute for advanced study
which is the house
that einstein built like like babe ruth
built the yankee stadium
and maybe we'll go there because i think
you're good
viewers in my yeah my channel will
really appreciate this
i had a conversation with juan maldasena
who is widely considered to be
you know maybe second only to ed whitton
or people like that
in terms of the brilliance at the at the
institute for advanced study
and i've been lucky to be able to get
interviews i'm trying to get ed whitton
and maybe i'll start a you know write in
campaign from your listeners and my
listeners he's never
really done a podcast but so too juan
had never done a podcast
and he is very famous in in physics
community and outside of it
for uh for really considerations that
revolve around
extra dimensions the properties of the
early expanding universe
something called anti-dep the sitter
space and what's called conformal field
theory
these are really abstract but very very
fascinating
instances of physics at extreme and
extreme behaviors in the early universe
and near wormholes and the of course the
question of whether or not a wormhole
exists is a totally open question
what juan maldonado attracted my
attention for recently and why he agreed
to come on my show
was because i i
noted that he had uh had
produced several papers he is really
looking at
whether or not the properties of a
wormhole
could sustain travel through
space effectively uh faster than the
speed of light or at extreme velocities
and could be transportable of the human
body
in other words they would have a
diameter which would support the
uh the traversal using uh by a human
being perhaps in some kind of a tube or
spacecraft or something like that
so he looked at the implications of that
and he started out with uh
with some really powerful and
interesting ideas of a friend of mine by
the name of
lisa randall at harvard uh who wrote a
wonderful book called war passages in
which she talks about
these extra dimensions and she had
discovered
uh or she had predicted along with a
colleague randall sundrum
i believe he's at the university of
maryland and they had predicted this
uh this you know possibility for these
extra dimensions which we would call
large extra dimensions
and the large extra dimensions would
create uh
would create the properties that would
be potentially conducive
for uh for gravity to
have both long-range forces and in some
sense be able to be unified
with uh with with quantum mechanics in
in the sense that i can get into
but the but the topic i just put that at
least in my channels um
in my channels uh live chat uh i don't
know can i just paste it into your
channel uh how do i do it uh
yeah should be able to yeah okay i'll
try that send you a message
no that's that's that's the help thing
there's a chat box on there you can't do
it from the oh no you can't do it from
this app
you got to do it i can't do it from the
app oh that's too bad yeah yeah from the
youtube channel
okay that's fine i'll do it later i put
in my thing um
so what randall and sundrum came up with
was that you could have these
large extra dimensions in other words
the universe that we inhabit has three
spatial dimensions
one time dimension unified by einstein
into what we call space-time
four-dimensional space-time but what
randall and sundrum proposed
is that they noted the following thing
if gravity is very weak but uh because
it's so weak it propagates
across the entirety of the universe in a
way that say the strong nuclear force
the weak nuclear force cannot
and they said well what if there was an
extra dimension that we can't really
perceive in the fourth dimension any
more than a creature living in the
second dimension
could perceive what it means to go you
know on a sphere or something like that
they can understand maybe what a circle
looks like
but they couldn't understand a sphere
maybe we can't really comprehend it
uh in terms of physical manifestation
but what if there was an
extra dimension a fourth spatial
dimension
and that dimension could be located say
near us in a certain sense
that you could have a circle on a piece
on a piece of paper on the table
and then you could have a beach ball you
know just a few inches away
and they couldn't perceive each other
and there would be an existence of an
extra dimension where the beach ball
could propagate into the
second dimension and reveal itself as
this famous book called flatland
talks about one of the most influential
books in my life uh which i'm planning
to do a special episode about soon
but um but getting back to this she
predicted
yeah edwin allen that's right uh so
randall and sunder predicted well there
could be a fifth dimension a fourth
spatial dimension
that's close to us in some abstract
sense in the in this fifth
in this fourth spatial dimension space
and uh
and from there gravity could leak from
the fourth dimension to the three
dimensions that we inhabit
meaning that it could propagate across
the entirety of the of the observable
universe potentially
and and and that's called the randall
syndrome cosmology or randall syndrome
uh spacetime and what mal the cena did
is he said in such a universe what would
the properties of quantum mechanics be
like
and basically he found that there's
certain ways that you could
you could um uh unify
the gravity of the fifth dimension with
the quantum mechanics of the
three dimensions that we inhabit in
which case you could spontaneously
create
this wormhole which would allow the
propagation
instantaneously effectively although the
particle itself wouldn't wouldn't get
transported back in time
it could go relatively traveled
macroscopic distances
in microscopic amounts of time so that
at some level it could be propagating
essentially as fast as the speed of
light or faster
even though it has mass which is
normally precluded
in the understanding of special
relativity that we understand a massive
object
like you or i cannot travel at the speed
of light without an infinite amount of
energy
so this is very fascinating to me do i
believe it absolutely not
there are all sorts of problems with it
not the least of which is we have no
evidence for the fifth dimension
so how could it be that you rely and
this by the way this only works you can
only make
a human traversable wormhole you can
make a wormhole
where where a particle could transmit
itself through so
microscopic wormhole theoretically you
could do that in four dimensions
but it's not clear if you could do a
large macroscopic
say one meter diameter half meter
diameter wormhole
that a human being could traverse now i
don't see tony again
uh can folks let me know uh am i visible
still
in in the fourth dimension uh tony seems
to have disappeared can someone put in
the chat if you can see me
i'll keep uh blathering on about my
conversation with wild melvacena
if you do indeed see me uh in the chat
room i still see myself i see myself
yep okay tony is crashing it so what's
interesting to me
is that what uh
professor maldisana is saying but i do
in in that there are these traversable
wormholes sorry tony we lost you for
another few minutes
i know it's my this is a brand new
laptop and it
it keeps crashing i have to completely
reboot so
don't worry don't worry anyway that's i
i i was i was listening to
the point up to the um the gravitational
waves
leaking through space-time and then i
was gone so
unfortunately i didn't get to finish
what you completely said but don't say
it again because i don't want to
force people uh to have to hear a repeat
on it but um
sorry about that what's so interesting
about what maldasena and i talked about
is that it actually connects together um
you know this kind of uh entanglement
between particles that einstein and
rosen
had talked about way back when but
what's so fascinating about these
wormholes is that they do seem to
require
this extra dimension and there's no
really
essential reason that we would have to
believe that a fifth dimension is
necessary
except possibly to unify gravity and
quantum mechanics
but again you know what you know
wolfgang paoli i think he originally
said something like who ordered that
like
why do we need to have uh this this
unification of gravity and quantum
mechanics
uh if they're only possible to be
manifest
at singularities where we have no
evidence that singularities exist
so i found it very interesting these
nobel prizes the conversation i had with
juan maldasena
and the properties of black holes now
which of the of the nobel prizes is sort
of near and dear to my heart it's really
the observation
and uh of these orbits of stars because
that's
that's mechanics tony that is the
application
of the laws of mechanics of orbits at
some level
newtonian mechanics not even relativity
uh only the very closest stars that they
image for decades
but it's a story of perseverance it's a
story of using massive telescopes
it's a california story it's a
university of california story
and it's also a story of you know of a
woman who's persisted against
you know kind of extreme odds you know
you think about tony
i didn't know this but vera rubin was
one of the first women to ever get
allowed to observe with a massive
telescope in this case the palomar
200-inch telescope
and it was only in the late 60s and
early 70s
when she was allowed to observe it and
she didn't have to pretend that she was
married to an astronomer
you know she was actually a titanic
figure in astronomy
and only 50 years ago she would have
been forbidden and now we've got
the first woman you know to win a nobel
prize for
essentially observational astronomy and
uh
and and and the persistence that she had
and the technical tour de force that her
group
uh really emboldened and and
demonstrated
i just i'm very happy about that
personal side
yeah and i didn't know that either uh
it's funny
you know nowadays what we look at as a
socially acceptable way of doing science
uh is really rather
recent uh it is even in our own lifetime
mine too
uh that things have changed so much um
all right i want to go back to the nobel
prize thing for a minute because
uh roger penrose was one of the awardees
today
or this week and um i was reading i want
to see if i can bring this up hopefully
i can
and this is uh i was reading ethan
siegel today
and um he published this article on
um get my cursor
and uh he published this article about
uh
i guess um with with roger penrose
um uh definitely
you know here's the article by the way
it's on forbes and he wrote it today
uh he definitely deserved the the work
he got things like that but i want to
read this part here he goes
unfortunately
nobel laureate roger penrose although
his work on general relativity black
holes and singularities in the 60s and
70s was absolutely nobel worthy
has spent a large amount of his efforts
in recent years on a crusade
to overthrow inflation okay by vastly
promoting
a vastly scientifically inferior
alternative
something called conformal cyclic
cosmology
and i don't want to go into what that is
only the point that he was making here
towards the bottom
of the article is uh this paragraph here
while we should laud
the creativity of penrose and celebrate
his groundbreaking nobel worthy work
we must guard ourselves against the urge
to deify any
great scientists or the work they engage
in that isn't supported by the data
in the end regardless of celebrity or
fame is up to the universe itself to
discern for us what's real and what's
merely an unsubstantiated hypothesis
and for us to follow the universe's lead
regardless of where
it takes us and this reminds me of
the part of einstein's life where he was
spent a great part of it
also looking for a theory of everything
and
so my question to you is this do
nobel prize does winning the nobel prize
do you think
give you a sense that anything you think
is is worth uh listening to
um because in the case of certainly this
this ccc model
of inflate of trying to get rid of
inflation it seems almost like a willful
disregard of what the
data are showing us about the
observations certainly
support inflation um and and to what
extent do you think
this bleeds over this idea of winning
the i'm a nobel prize winner
what to what extent do you think it goes
into your science obviously it makes you
famous
but does it make you a better scientist
as a result of having won it
no i mean oftentimes i talk about in my
book losing the nobel prize
it has an awful you know degenerative
effect on the collaborations that led to
the nobel prize in the first place
as i said earlier i didn't uh maybe
finish it but the
but the nobel prize for ligo i get
emails from people that are
disgruntled that they weren't even
mentioned they didn't get a penny
you know that they if they did a
tremendous amount of work they should be
recognized
um and so it tends to distort the way
that science is actually
uh historically presented in other words
you go back and you say
well kip thorne and barry barish and ray
weiss
they were the three founding pioneers
and in fact there was a
there was another person and barry
barish only came along later and
he's of course he's actually a friend
and a great scientist obviously
uh but he came along after ron dreiberg
you know had
declined and in in health and and so
forth but what you're talking about is
called the
the halo effect and it's a form of bias
called authority bias where
you think of somebody as an authority in
all things because they're expert in one
thing
uh for example uh einstein was asked to
be the first president of the state of
israel in 1948
uh but he knew nothing about politics i
mean he had some really kind of dumb
ideas about politics and and that
anti-nationalism
and and you know kind of things that led
to you know
and i'm not criticizing him it's just in
retrospect you know
being a pacifist wouldn't have played
out so well uh in world war ii
and so i i think i think he has a
similar idea now
you'll also get the effect that
sometimes you'll get all these nobel
prize winners will come out and say
you shouldn't sign a treaty with iran or
you should vote for these people every
year
this year 77 nobel laureates told us
that we should vote for joe biden
now what does someone who uh won a nobel
prize in 1968
know about in condensed matter physics
uh
know about uh current politics in the
global scene no it's
they're clearly only getting attention
because they want a nobel prize and
that's part of the idolatry
of nobel prize winners that i talk about
in my book and look
i suffered from it too uh early in my
career that was a huge motivation to win
a nobel prize
because i think when you lack you know
other
kind of outlets as i did maybe back then
or want to achieve this level of fame
and authority
that's the surest way up the ladder uh
now things are different for me but but
getting back to what ethan said
specifically
look he criticizes most things he's a
very uh oppositional very contrarian
thinker
uh what roger has done is he's done
something very valuable in the conformal
cyclic cosmology
and made it such that inflation is not a
monopoly
and whether or not i don't believe
necessarily in the conformal cyclic
cosmology
but to have things like ethan is
proclaiming that you can't that he's
doing damage to science by talking about
the lacunae
the problems in uh in inflation i think
that's outlandish and i think that you
know ethan is is way off base there
uh because it's i don't think he's
saying that so much as he's just um
uh uh putting forth
a um uh
the the the the justification for why he
says this is working
is is it depends on how you look at the
data for example
and um i'm trying to i don't i can't
find the i can't find
the uh uh well he's saying something
you know that the universe will tell us
what the answer look the universe
doesn't tell us anything we don't get
like well that wasn't from well that was
from jupiter right we get data and so
what roger has done is he's made a
prediction it happens to be his
predictions have been way off base and
i've actually challenged him about this
in person
there are consequences that he calls
hawking points that he
says are present even in the bicep 2
data
and then i've uh personally disabused
him of when he's come to san diego as i
said in the beginning of the podcast
he's a friend of mine personally and
he's
trying to have the penrose institute at
uc san diego in part at uc san diego
i've talked to him about the many many
problems with the conformal cyclic
cosmology
proof so to speak from the bicep data
which is something i'm very expert in
understanding
so i'm i am saying he's predicted
something that's falsifiable
inflation may or may not be falsifiable
and that's the problem with people like
steinhardt
uh who also ethan has expressed uh you
know kind of uh some
some sincere criticisms for uh but
you know i think i think uh what ethan's
maybe
uh mis appropriating is that roger's
gonna take the nobel prize
you know fame or whatever and and then
apply that and say everybody believe in
conformal cyclic cosmology
that's not the way science works i think
ethan knows that i i think
he's he's very very staunchly in this
realm that
inflation is right it's been proven
when again inflation as i always point
out
is not the same as the big bang it's not
the beginning of time
inflation is a paradigm that explains
most successfully
when considering as a formation of
structure
not as a theory of how the cosmos came
to be for that
even uh even people like alan guth and
andre linde
say that you need essentially need the
multiverse hypothesis
and then the question is is the
multiverse you know more plausible than
the conformal cyclic cosmology
uh i think it's healthy to have
alternative ideas
and roger's the most creative he pointed
out major problems with inflation
such as the entropy problem you know how
do you get to extremely low entropy so
that nowadays you have really high
entropy
he was the first to really point that
out and yes he's kind of outspoken about
it
but he's a treasure and i think um
i for one you know we're not going to
listen to him just because he won the
nobel prize and all of a sudden
uh he's right about everything that
would be extreme
halo effect right and i i couldn't agree
more so i just before i leave this
though i don't want to
give the wrong impression of what i was
trying to say i just want to read this
one part
because i really this is the part i was
trying to find the predictions that he's
made
are refuted by the data and his claims
to see these effects are only
reproducible if one analyzes the data
in a scientific uh scientifically
unsound and illegitimate fashion
doesn't say what that is hundreds of
scientists have pointed this out to
penrose repeatedly and consistently over
a period of more than 10 years
who continues to ignore the field and
plow ahead with his contentions
so that's what brought up my
bring this subject to begin with it's
this idea and much like what fred hoyle
i think he also uses this as in his
article as an example
really hated the big bang and um
but uh couldn't really
i could just say uh couldn't really um
uh
the the the observations clearly
overweighed what he was
his his uh attempts at trying to make
the big bank go away
and i think he was trying to draw a
parallel between that thinking from fred
hoyle
and what penrose is doing now with his
uh
yeah of course you know hoyle deserved
the nobel prize for his work on
nuclear synthesis and stars and because
he criticized the dominant paradigm
and he actually criticized the nobel
academy which is a real no-no which
suggests you know my chances are
very limited to infinitesimal i may have
a singularity of exactly
zero
so yeah so i i understand completely
that argument
uh but you know on the other hand what
would you do stifle it and and
and ethan's wrong in the sense that you
know it's not like we're gonna rogers
gonna slip things past the editors at
physical review
because now he's got a nobel prize i
mean look how many nobel prize winners
have
gone into ignominity you know this guy
tim was named
um tim smith he's the biologist who
complained that women are
no good in the lab and then just
ridiculous he was forced to resign
uh try getting a paper published after
that or jim watson you know for
for all the kind of questionable if not
purely
odious things that he said about or you
know different races and
william shockley of course felt that
african-americans were inferior and
should be eugenically
dealt it's just terrible so i don't
think ethan should really worry that
because he won a nobel prize for work in
numerical and
in mathematical relativity uh that he's
obviously going to slip
all these articles past the goal post in
fact as far as i know
uh the papers that he submitted have not
been accepted they've not been published
he gets attention in like new scientist
magazine but that's not a journal
that's not a scientific journal that's
uh you know it's like scientific
american it's it's important it's
popular
it's it's it's relevant but it's not a
scientific there's no peer review that
goes into it so ethan
should rest assured um that uh because
he won a nobel prize it's not like
we're going to start teaching a
conformal cyclic cosmology
in every you know undergraduate
cosmology class that's not likely to
happen
but i don't think we should suppress it
either uh in that you know it's not like
teaching the controversy you know and we
should teach you know creationism
but instead it's something that it's
about
yeah it has many many uh appealing
points about it but as ethan points out
you know it's been refuted it hasn't
been published
and let him continue to go and and work
on it and if he does come up with
something
uh you know we we should pay attention
not not because he won a nobel prize
but because he's extraordinarily
creative and has had tremendous insights
in science
uh but we're not gonna just blindly
accept what he says uh
thanks to his winning the nobel prize
this week excellent oh yeah that's a
good point okay i want to leave it there
i know i i've got to go but i just
wonder do you have time for this quick
question from neil
yeah um who's asking what do you think
about neil turock's
uh anti-universe antiverse ideas
yeah those are really cool so from one
nil to another
neil you neil universe exactly
that's a really interesting uh concept
it kind of
parlays with some of neil turock's ideas
in the early 2000s what was called the
ek pyrotic universe
which is another form of cyclic or
collapse contraction
expansion universe in this case you have
an anti-universe
and a universe that are created at the
same time in a certain sense and that
conserves
uh certain symmetry preserves certain
symmetry properties
that physicists are very fond of uh you
know conserves
energy conservation um there are certain
momentum conservation things like that
i do believe it requires uh this you
know membranes or
extra dimensions in order for it at
least in its original incarnation
uh to to uh be sustained
i think it's uh i think it's an
interesting idea just like the
pyrotic was interesting but interesting
in the same way maldisana's ideas are
interesting in that
they might give you insight into quantum
gravity they might give you insight into
inflation they might give you
other spin-offs side ancillary benefits
from studying them even if there's not
necessarily a superiority advantage of
them
over inflation or over the big bang
singularity so i think they're worth
studying it's
very interesting um but uh but it may
also
eventually have to uh be a prize
appraised by the same tools that we
appraise things like the perotic
universe and
this conformal cyclic universe so it may
you know if it doesn't make testable
predictions
it may not be really uh incredibly
valuable to to cosmologists to pursue
but i think right now it's still it's an
interesting theoretical purely
theoretical topic
cool all right thanks for the question
neil i appreciate that um all right well
brian um
any closing thoughts before we go i have
had you for my full hour here
so yeah i really enjoy it yeah and we
should get back together i'm gonna have
some great guests
coming on my podcast in the next few
weeks i have nobel prize winner frank
wilcek
coming on my podcast in a few weeks he's
got a new book app
out uh i've also uh got a podcast
scheduled
uh akane hamed at the institute for
advanced study one of the most
brilliant people in the world i'm doing
a live stargazing event
with adam reese in november and
friedman yeah we're gonna do another
live stream
uh perhaps also with uh becky smethurst
of uh
dr becky's youtube channel so please
subscribe to my channel dr brian keating
and hopefully tony and i can continue
yeah so let's keep uh keep these
conversations going it's gonna be an
exciting uh couple of months on my
channel i hope you all agree
and i also had the honor and privilege
of being on eric weinstein's portal
podcast so look for that
coming hopefully soon although he's
pretty backed up on his podcast
and believe me i feel this pain it takes
me a long time to get my podcast
uh put out too so all right well dr
brian
thank you so much as always for taking
some time out to talk with us uh we'll
have
lots of cool stuff to talk about coming
forth in the future i want to thank all
of you guys for
your patience today and helping me with
my uh new setup here
hopefully i'll get the kinks worked out
eventually but not really because deep
astronomy and technical problems is just
what we are
so anyway i will be streaming tonight on
the clear skies network uh on twitch if
you want to check out
a rambling stream that i will put
together as i speak
so i'll talk to you guys tonight on
twitch 9 o'clock eastern time clear
skies network
on behalf of dr brian keating i'm tony
darnell thank you all so much for
watching
and as always keep looking up
you